earlier this week i received a comment
on my magic leap video asking me to do a
deep dive into lytro
i was only vaguely familiar with the
product so i did some research and put
together some thoughts on the company
and why it never received mass adoption
i think it's a really interesting case
study in the race between
hardware and software solutions to
common problems
let's jump right into it lytro designed
and sold what are called light field
cameras
meaning that they capture not only the
intensity of light in a scene
but also the direction that the light
rays are traveling
by capturing this extra data the focus
of the resulting image can be changed
after the fact
everyone has tried to capture an
important moment only to later realize
that the subject was blurry
with a light field camera that problem
promises to be a thing of the past
the inner workings of a light field
camera are extremely complex
so i'll let larry greenmeyer from
scientific american explain how it works
a light field camera lets you fix the
focus of an image even after it's been
taken
so how does it work the image sensor in
a normal digital camera
adds up all the rays of light around
whatever you're photographing and counts
them as a single amount of light
it's helpful to use music as an analogy
taking a conventional digital photo
is like recording all the instruments in
a band all at once
a light field camera on the other hand
would be like recording individual
instruments on separate audio tracks
that's because a light field camera uses
a special sensor to record the color and
intensity of light
traveling in every direction to every
point in space
breaking down a song into individual
tracks lets you fine-tune the sound
in the same way breaking down a photo
into individual rays of light
lets you improve the clarity of a
picture even after it's been taken
let's use the lytro lightfield camera as
an example of how this works
a lytro camera has a lens a light field
sensor
and a microprocessor this setup isn't
too different from a normal digital
camera
what is different about the lightro is
that its sensor is covered by a matrix
of microlenses
these provide an enormous amount of
information about direction
color and intensity of light then the
lytros microprocessor figures out what
an image should look like when it's in
focus
although the technology is advanced you
can immediately see the benefits of this
type of camera
so why aren't we all using lightfield
cameras now
well the company was founded in 2006 and
it's important to remember how different
the world of photography was back then
the iphone hadn't been announced yet and
cnet had just crowned the sony ericsson
k800i
the best camera phone of the year and it
only had a 3.2 megapixel camera
at the higher end canon had just
launched the 5d mark 1
which was a breakthrough in digital
photography but it only shot 12
megapixel images
and it cost over three thousand dollars
and that's before you bought a lens
additionally instagram wouldn't launch
until four years later
so photo sharing was still in its
infancy it took
six years for the company to launch its
first product to market and by the time
the consumers got their hands on the
first lytro camera
technology had advanced significantly
the boxy design was awkward for most
users
and the post-processing workflow was
extremely tedious since the photos
couldn't be edited in photoshop or
lightroom
the ability to change focus after
shooting was definitely cool but reviews
were mixed and the product never took
off
to lightro's credit the team was able to
release a second camera in just two
years
the new camera produced more detailed
images and featured a more ergonomic
design
unfortunately for lytro though reviews
were again mixed
editing photos from the camera still
required the use of lytro special app
and it never gained adoption from
mainstream photographers it's important
to remember that focus is just
one factor that makes a photo look
professional the lighting composition
and colors all play huge roles
and while lytro made focusing easier it
made tweaking lighting composition and
color balance in post-production
extremely difficult
and it's not like the rest of the
photography industry had been asleep
while lytro was working on their cameras
canon launched dual pixel autofocus in
2013
which made nailing perfect focus on
high-end and prosumer cameras extremely
easy and reliable
additionally apple introduced portrait
mode in 2016 with the iphone 7.
by using two separate lenses on the new
iphone apple's image processing pipeline
would be able to produce photos that
look like they were taken with a
telephoto lens
and this was just the beginning of
computational photography in the last
four years
camera sensors on smartphones have
essentially plateaued
resolution is a crude measure of sensor
quality but the last five generations of
iphones have all been 12 megapixels
all the innovation is happening on the
software side now features like night
mode
smart hdr and portrait mode are all
driven primarily by advances in
computational photography
and with the ubiquity of modern social
media what's the point of a great photo
if you can't share it with the world in
a single click
faced with all of these headwinds lytro
attempted to shift their focus to vr
video capture
but again their solution wasn't
applicable to a wide range of users
it's really unfortunate because light
field technology has incredible
applications for vr
just look at this amazing demo from
google earlier this year
our pipeline produces volumetric free
viewpoint video that can be explored
with six degrees of freedom within a
spherical
70 centimeter diameter viewing volume
our capture rig consists of 46
time synchronized action sports cameras
mounted on a 92
centimeter diameter plastic hemisphere
it is inexpensive
and relatively easy to fabricate the
cameras are roughly 18 centimeters apart
and each has a 120 degree
by 90 degree field of view their
overlapping fields of view support
reconstruction of objects close to the
dome surface
in these scenes we show near field
objects as close as half a meter from
the cameras
while that demo is cool it really shows
how far this technology
is from general consumer adoption that
google rig is far too large for any
reasonable consumer to use
and the adoption of vr head mounted
displays is still low
additionally that google demo relies on
an incredible amount of software to
process the video feeds and interpolate
different views to construct the video
volume
the hardware is actually pretty simple
the story of lytro
really illustrates how hard it is to
bring a new hardware device to market
even a huge success like gopro is still
worth less than a billion dollars
while instagram was acquired for a
billion dollars only two years after
launch
there's a saying in silicon valley that
hardware is hard and stories like lytro
really enforce that
but what do you think did you ever use a
lytro camera leave me a comment below
and consider subscribing if you enjoyed
this video
thanks for watching